im moment wird es wieder heiß diskutiert
dsds thomas d hat sich ja im rahmen von
unser star für baku da sehr kritisch
über die leute rund um dieter bohlen
geäußert auch bei uns die rote frage zum
thema warum muss sie denn jetzt in so
einer jury mit machen das und viel mehr
jetzt infrage lotto mit cascada wobei
dann wird ja auch heftig darüber
diskutiert ist es natalie horler ist es
cascada natürlich ist es die truppe mit
zwei kumpels aber sie nennt sich selbst
auch cascada wir in einem der videos
sicher gesehen hat also man kann es so
oder so sehen und jetzt viel spaß beim
fragen lotto bis dann dran
das ist das fragen lotto da sind gemein
und harmlose franken drin okay wir haben
sie aber farblich gekennzeichnet die
roten sind gemein die grünen sind haben
dass du kannst selbst wählen du kannst
selbst also kannst dann auch wenn du
siehst noch entscheiden ob du zu
verantworten willst also hast alle
möglichkeiten aber es sind fragen drin
die wir so in positiven und dem
negativen wahrscheinlich noch nicht
gestellt worden sind okay ganz blind
reingreifen eselei geht so
ich liebe diese dinge aufmachen das
erinnert an diese lose hatten wir haben
ja es ist es ist immer ein gewinn
was ist das wirkliche geheimnis des
cascada erfolges wenn ich statt vista
jetzt kannst du mich irgendwie hat es
nicht so was man sagt ja das ist unser
rezept unterfangen war kein weiter ja
eigentlich nicht um ehrlich zu sein weil
das ich wurde ganz auf das boxen ich
wurde schon hundertmal diese frage
gestellt okay und ich antworte
eigentlich immer gleich das wenn wir
natürlich dieses rezept müssten dann
wäre das alles total einfacher künstlers
jan wie anwenden an jede band an jede
sängerin jeden sänger und dann wenn man
erfolgreich das ist natürlich quatsch
ich glaube es hat sehr viel mit glück zu
tun ich glaube es hat sehr viel mit am
richtigen ort zum richtigen zeitpunkt
irgendwie da zu sein und gefechten wie
sagt man den ton der zeitschrift werben
derzeit mehr hat derzeit ja genau und
irgendwie das den leuten zu erheben ist
ja dass den leuten zu geben was sie auch
hören möchten ich hoffe dass es auch mit
mir zu tun hat persönlich was ich
ausstrahle dass sie dass die fans sich
mit mir identifizieren können dass die
texte stimmen dass sie spaß an der musik
haben also ich glaube wenn wir auf die
bühne gehen ist es schon unheimlich
wichtig dass die leute richtig mit einem
lächeln nach hause gehen dass die wir
versuchen die wirklich kaputt zu machen
also also auf positive art also wir
versuchen die wirklich zum austicken zu
bringen weil wir machen wir entnehmen
von denen auch so viel energie und ich
glaube dass die leute dann auch richtig
spaß haben und vielleicht ist das
also doch ein unglück
manager wird jetzt zittern daneben
sitzen
muss man heute in die jury einer
castingshow um die album verkäufe
anzukurbeln
tja mir hat das niemand gedacht hat dort
passiert relativ super
ganz ehrlich nee also ich denke für mich
ist es eine coole erfahrung dass man zu
machen generell ich beschäftige mich
viel mit musik und wenn man die chance
hat vielleicht teil davon zu sein dass
man jemanden neues talent entdeckt und
jemand die chance geben kann ist
natürlich super auf der anderen seite
natürlich ist das wenn man sagen wir mal
gemacht lange musikern ist im fernsehen
vielleicht nicht ganz so viel in der
öffentlichkeit was einfach generell
jemand als öffentliche person auch
weiter in die innere öffentlich machen
kann dann ist das natürlich eine super
sache so ne aber man kann sich so was
natürlich nicht erzwingen also die die
müssen ja auch ein ansprechen und fragen
leute selber machen oder ja ich war vor
zehn jahren oder oder so war ich mal da
und da ist das war natürlich alles noch
das geschäftsjahr für aber wie gesagt
ich darauf werde ich auch sehr häufig
angesprochen wenn ich sehe was die
kandidaten alles erleben und um die
waren ja mit auf den malediven und was
er sich das ist natürlich nicht
vergleichbar mit den zwei minuten die
ich da war ich habe davor gesungen an
einem tag hat ein paar stunden gewartet
dann haben sie gesagt nee ist nicht und
das war's das ist natürlich eine ganz
andere das ist keine lebens prägende
erfahrungen die ich da gemacht hat
deswegen aber nee also die frage ist
eigentlich quatsch weil die für mich hat
diese theorie sache diese theorie salat
für mich gar nichts mit meiner
musikalischen karriere wirklich zu tun
eigentlich nicht es gibt nämlich nachher
die hollister auch cascada aber nicht
wirklich also sind trotzdem irgendwie so
zwei sachen cascada ist halt auf tour
gehen und singen und das tun das tun und
diese theorie sache ich singe nicht sich
sitzt da und gibt meine musikalische
meinung einfach dazu ab das ist einfach
so ein bisschen so eine andere karriere
richtung auch nebenbei machen und das
gefällt mir richtig gut also wird ja ja
ich finde das schön auch mal ist genauso
wie andere leute sagen ich möchte mal
mit der schauspielerei was probieren und
so weiter das ist halt einfach mal was
anderes und das ist dass ich genieße das
genauso aber für mich wird die musik hat
immer an erster stelle bleiben
englischen hatte ja schon die ein oder
andere tv show moderiert ja so ein
bisschen aus waren immer nur ab und zu
da wird man halt gastmoderatorin da
irgendwie gefragt mal was zu machen und
das hat mir richtig was war also da habe
ich damals auch gedacht hey so was würde
ich auch gerne noch nebenbei machen also
man man ist ja dann voller ambition und
ehrgeizig und hat lust verschiedene
sachen ausprobieren ich würde sagen noch
eine zum abschluss weil der auftritt
nach
da hab ich dir das hier abonnieren danke
was macht cascada so einzigartig tja so
ziemlich die andere frage in ruhe
was machst du eigentlich sehr die frage
sind wir einzigartig jeder jede band
irgendwo jede person jeder künstler ist
einzigartig weil der erfolgreiches
einzigartig denn
man muss ja irgendwann haben und da habe
ich meine ausstrahlung irgendwas profile
man stets charmant ab und zu kriegt man
noch mit die vergleiche um die ohren
gehauen das wird sie haben wie lady gaga
oder die sieht die macht ein auf lady
gaga oder diese heutzutage vergleichen
ja alle künstler miteinander
sobald im song klingt genauso wie das
oder die klamotten sind mal ein bisschen
ausgeflippt also ist wie gesagt sieht
diese aus idee das ist im endeffekt
quatsch a gibt es ist eine lady gaga
dann genauso wie madonna recycelt würde
ich auch nie behaupten aber das könnte
man auch jörg aber aber jeder ist
einzigartig und jeder ist sein eigener
mensch und das ist bei mir halt genauso
ich meine auch wenn nicht tausend andere
sängerinnen gibt die auch dance-musik
singen das macht jedoch nicht irgendwie
gleich zu mir deswegen
einzigartig ist einfach jeder was mich
einzigartig macht kann ich ja auch nicht
wirklich erklären
ich bin einfach mit ihnen fertig nach
maddie wenn man ja ja auch meine
freundin nämlich alle nett
ich glaube es kommt mehr auf englisch
denn die mich na und dann hat sich das
so mit meinen deutschen freunden so ein
bisschen angibt dass die seit märz nett
aber
sagt er ja glaube ich ja einzigartig und
könnte
danke vielmals danke ich kennen gelernt
dankeschön gleich